imaginez qu'une planète s'étaient
jusqu'ici caché dans notre système
solaire
elle était sur la même orbite que la
terre mais juste derrière le soleil ce
qui fait que personne n'avait pu
l'observer
on y voit des astronautes et là surprise
c'est un clone de la planète terre mais
totalement cubique à quoi ça
ressemblerait d'y vivre à sa surface
quels sont les problèmes de physique
qu'on y rencontrerait et surtout que
faudrait-il pour qu'une telle planète
prennent cette forme dans la réalité
pour cette expérience on va étudier des
logiciels 3d et le minecraft préparez
vous pour un grand voyage avec la limmat
art qu'est ce que ça ferait d'être sur
les bords d'une planète cubique
l'atterrissage sur la plaine public
s'est bien passé lui c'est notre
astronautes qui débarque et salles là
bas ou moins c'est le bord du monde
c'est étonnant mais contrairement la
terre l'horizon s'étend du pernois
normal puisque la face sur laquelle on
est est totalement plate pas de courbure
pour gâcher le spectacle comme vous êtes
curieux de savoir ce que ça fait quand
on est sur les bords mitton nous en août
déjà sur le chemin un truc bizarre ce
produit plus on s'éloigne plus on a
l'impression de monter
c'est pourtant impossible les façons
totalement plate c'est à cause d'une
chose toute simple la gravité cette
force qui semble nous tirer vers le
centre de la planète sur la terre
sérique le centre est sous nos pieds
qu importe où vous soyez en france en
australie le centre est à la même
distance mais sur une planète cubi plus
on se rapproche d'un bord plus on
s'éloigne du centre de la planète et
plus cette direction est incliné et ça
vous pouvez le vérifier avec une simple
feuille de papier en réalité les côtes
du cube sont pour toi comme des sortes
de chic quand est-ce que montagne de
3000 kilomètres de pau la perception de
la verticale est totalement chamboulé le
monde a beau être carré
gravitationnellement tu le ressens
direct comme ça il n'y a qu'au centre où
tu aurais le sentiment de gravité normal
tout lors sc de la pente si tu lâches un
ballon alors qu'il est en train de
monter le long d'à côté il ne va pas
tomber tout droit au sol
il va rouler vers le centre du carré et
tu commences à voir le problème les
bords de la planète ne sont ni verdoyant
ni aquatique
clos va être attirés vers le centre de
cette immense cuve est gravitationnelle
ce qui fait qu'il y aura littéralement
une pub l'océan au centre de chaque
phase de la planète public
bon ça s'annonce mal mais continuons
l'ascension heureusement plus on
s'éloigne du centre - subit la gravité
et donc pèsent moins lourd
ça représente 60% de notre poids
habituel c'est déjà ça mais petit à
petit il fait de plus en plus froid et
ta respiration devient difficile on
arrive en fait aux limites de la bulle
atmosphérique dont on a retiré les
rebelles est là qu il faut maintenant te
retirer l'air et le ciel peut aussi sont
attirés vers le centre pour former une
bulle est justement là on arrive aux
limites de cette bulle atmosphérique
au delà c'est le vide spatial et oui sur
une place publique on peut aller dans
l'espace à pied mais vous ce qui vous
intéresse c'est de savoir ce qu'il y à
holly mythe du cube qu'est ce que ça
fait de pouvoir s'asseoir sur les
rebords du monde eh bien désolé mais tu
tomberas pas tu pourras te tenir debout
au sommet du monde en équilibre comme si
tu étais au sommet d'une montagne tu te
sentirais très léger et tu pourrez
contempler une vue magnifique sur quatre
face de la planète
sauf que il ya quelque chose qui cloche
si face si paysages très différents au
sommet de la montagne gravitationnelle
tu découvres qu'une d'effacer
complètement glacée est morte
et oui sur une terre ronde l'inclinaison
fait qu'on ne reçoit pas la même
quantité de soleil suivant notre
position est le moment de l'année mais
sur une terre cubique tous les rayons
arrive avec le même englobe pas de
saison pas de fuseaux horaires toujours
12 heures de jour et 12 heures de nuit
soit l'axé vertical et passe par deux
faces là deux faces polaire qui ne
reçoivent quasiment jamais de lumière
glacée est morte ou sinon quatre phases
qui en reçoivent un maximum c'est l'été
toute l'année assez aride comme qui m'a
quand même
mais si on prend comme notre terre un
axe incliné les deux faces polaire
seront dans la nuit la moitié de l'année
et assisteront à un coucher de soleil 2
mois c'est déjà en quelque sorte ce
qu'il se passe au pôle et sur les autres
face à peu près le même climat qu'on a
actuellement en europe
mais le paramètre à prendre le plus en
compte c'est que chaque fois c'est
totalement séparées par du vide spatial
ce qui fait que l'atmosphère reste au
centre qui rend impossible les grands
mouvements d'air et d'eau qui régule la
température sur notre terre pas de
perturbation ni de vents violents
toujours la même météo au même rythme
pour des millions d'années mais si tu
veux de l' aventure rappelle toi que
toutes les bulles d'atmosphère sont
totalement séparés il ya littéralement
si monde en un autrement dit la vie qui
s'est développée sur une autre face à
peut-être suivi une évolution
complètement différente
pas besoin de chercher très loin des
aliens pourrait se trouver sur la même
planète
est ce que la vie est possible sur une
planète cubique rappelle toi quand on a
dit que l'atmosphère former une bulle
sur chaque face et ça c'est pas sans
conséquence au centre l'atmosphère y
tellement compris mais qu'on atteint des
pressions des températures énorme
c'est une cocotte-minute plus truc hors
de question d'y vivre
al'inverse au delà de la bulle cannoise
aux mains d'air et celle vide spatial
ce qui nous laisse une zone habitable
réduite un anneau d'une quarantaine de
kilomètres de large pas grand du tout
qu'ils croient marathon était arrivé à
l'autre bout un marathon un peu
particulier puisque à cause de la
montagne gravitationnelle tu serais tout
temps penché comme si tu étais en
permanence en forte pente ce monde
serait plutôt adapté des chamois par
exemple parce que j'ai oublié de vous
dire mais ouais vous avez beau être à
plat vous pouvez tomber et glisser vers
le centre c'est la mort assurée
tellement les conditions sont extrêmes
ça ne veut pas non plus dire que la vie
au centre serait impossible par exemple
au fond des océans on pourrait retrouver
ce genre de poisson abyssal ou des
limaces de mer des mariannes le
vertébrés qui vit le plus en profondeur
au monde
les hautes températures n'est prêt pas
quant à elle les bactéries
hyperthermophiles qui elle se régale de
la présence des magmas à proximité des
volcans sous marins
al'inverse vers l'extérieur lorsque
l'air se raréfie on pourrait retrouver
des edelweiss surnommés les toiles des
glaciers car elle arrive à pousser à des
altitudes impressionnante où l'air se
fait très rare
comme on l'a dit nous humains nous ne
pouvons vivre que sur ce petit anneau il
y en a un autre très propice à la vie et
c'est celui légèrement vers l'intérieur
l'air il serait tellement dense et épais
qu'on pourrait presque nager dedans il
est très probable que les oiseaux soient
favorisés par ces conditions du coup
suivant la distance au centre la
biodiversité et l'environnement seront
très différents on passerait d'une sorte
de vénus au centre a eu un terreau
fertile une mars et enfin paysage
lunaire tout ça sur la même planète
à quelques kilomètres de marche avec les
pressions et températures immonde
au centre on n'est pas sûr que le cycle
de l'eau pourra s'accomplir or sans
pluie pas d'eau non pas de vie mais le
spectacle le plus fou ce passera le soir
comme on l'a dit le centre est une
immense bulle d'eau de 30000 mètres de
haut
tu auras droit chaque soir à un coucher
de soleil à travers une montagne océans
une scène féerique unique en son genre
mais interpublic
est ce vraiment possible vous en doutez
une planète cubique ce n'est pas normal
la planète chercheur a fatalement à
reprendre sa position d'équilibré une
sphère dis toi que les arêtes sont
équivalentes à des montagnes de 3000
kilomètres de haut
à côté les huit kilomètres de l'everest
font pâle figure
même la roche ne peut pas soutenir tout
ce poids et avec le temps la terre va
petit à petit se ratatiner s'effondrer
se tasser bref s'arrondir au bout de
quelques milliers d'années elle sera
redevenu une banale ce faire dommage
en même temps c'est vrai qu'une planète
cubique on se demande bien comment elle
se serait formé d'ailleurs quand un
astronome suisse a fait les gros titres
en déclarant avoir trouvé une plaine
public en orbite autour de neptune même
le new york times s'est moqué de lui
parce que oui c'était faux alors qu'avez
vous pensé du voyage en explorant cette
étrange planète
je ne pensais pas qu'il y aurait autant
de choses à découvrir imaginez seulement
la beauté d'un tel paysage et que
j'aimerais tellement pouvoir le voir si
non en vrai au moins dans un jeu vidéo
je laisse la porte ouverte aux créateurs
aux rêveurs au dessinateur en espérant
un jour pouvoir voir ce monde en
mouvement planète québec
pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne sayan
strache si vous voulez une suite avec
d'autres formes de planètes s'étaient
9,6 m'attarde sky antoine idy de tous
les moteurs merci à vous tous
[Musique]